yeah i'm very excited that we started
our link academy live our three members
hannah emily and thomas are here i had a
short meeting with them i explained my
vision that
basically we're in a new world of
language learning we're learners our
teachers teachers are learners and we
learn from the world around us and
that's essentially what we're going to
be doing over the next three months and
so you might find the
our little discussion interesting and
there will be more videos along these
lines over the next three months so stay
tuned
i can actually remember when i was
roughly your age
i can actually remember
uh and at that time you know i spoke two
languages i spoke essentially
uh english and french
and i was just starting to get involved
chinese
and
of course those were for me first of all
discovering everything surrounding
french and french culture was a
great discovery and the more i
got involved and got interested in
things french french movies french
history whatever the better my french
became obviously and the same was true
with chinese where i discovered this
whole new world of
chinese and since that time of course
i've learned many other languages so
you have the opportunity to
eventually speak many many languages i
know you're interested not only in
english
and uh
so what we're going to do
and just before i get into the details
of how we're going to approach our
english program and stop me if there's
anything you don't understand right
um i just want i think i think what is
happening in the world of education
is that like if i think back to when i
studied languages you know you learned a
school
school was the source there is school
teacher school that's where you learn
that was the only place to learn
which in fact in my case
even then wasn't really the case
because as long as i relied on school
for example for french i couldn't speak
french
but when i got interested in french
movies when i got interested in
of course i lived in montreal so
even though there were a million
anglophones in montreal if i wanted to
access the french culture there i could
so to the extent that i got away from
the classroom i learned more
but the amount of language
that the sort of scale of language
learning opportunity that we have today
is so much bigger than was the case 50
years ago
i mean it's
there's no comparison
when i think of how i use the internet
my ipad you know different technology
including link of course
audiobooks ebooks i mean there's so much
more stuff
conversations by the internet there's so
many more reasons why
today education is not the school
education is
the world
accessible through all the modern means
of of uh
you know communication mp3 files youtube
i mean you name it right
so i think what's happening is
that
and i think that's what we're going to
experience here
is that in a way the role of the teacher
and the learner
changes a bit
learners become teachers teachers become
learners it's learners learn from each
other i mean it's that kind of an
environment so what we're going to do in
the next three months is we're going to
work on with you on english specifically
and
and he's going to
film this so that other people will be
following what we're doing
and so it's all part of this idea that
people are helping each other sharing
with each other learning from each other
and you know in the initial period i'm
going to talk about my experience
my experience of learning languages what
i think works
but i hope after a month or so i want to
hear about your ideas of what you think
works
and so we'll be talking about these
things and other people who are
following it
will also hopefully be stimulated by
this and they might come forward with
their ideas so it's kind of like a we
call it sometimes our okay link academy
live a reality show but it's a reality
show with a message
it's not just about who gets kicked off
the island you know
it's actually about
uh
you know something that i think can be
helpful and beneficial to people so
now with regard to
our goals okay
so i in terms of
my working with you
i have three goals
three goals that i want to achieve
number one
i think you are already very much
independent learners otherwise you
wouldn't come here
i mean otherwise you'd simply go to the
local school so you are independent but
i'm hoping that we can make you even
more effective
independent learners
in other words people who go and find
content of interest who know what they
want to learn if they don't understand
something
having to do with grammar they know
where to find it on the internet and
stuff and they're finding their own
material and
finding things of interest to them and
through pursuing these things therefore
they're learning so but we're going to
talk about ways to become even better
independent learners that's the one
thing
the second thing is
we're going to talk about how to improve
our english right and
the big thing i think with improving the
english
is not only how much you will improve in
the next three months
but a lot of what you will do
the benefits the effects will be much
later
you know you don't just
study for three months and wow look how
you know i i know i'm perfect
you will improve
but you will also set in place things
that are gonna
have their effect
over the many many months that follow
so we will be looking at things that can
that will enable you to improve while
you're here but also to continue
improving and and so
in that sense you know we'll talk about
how link works
um
lots of listening and reading because i
happen to believe in listening and
reading
and but you as independent learners
you're going to go out and find stuff
that interests you
i think that
the material you should use initially
because we're talking about
learning and my approach to learning so
we'll start with some of my blog posts
some of my two youtube videos
which you will study and then we'll talk
about them
but that's kind of initially so it's my
ideas but later on i want to hear your
ideas but we're going to start with my
ideas okay
and but we also want you to get good at
finding content in the link library i
think you should subscribe online to
some newspapers and magazines in your
area of interest and study them on link
so it's a matter of you building up the
range of things that you want to use as
input right so it's
as i say on my blog my youtube videos
in newspaper magazines
also you should at some point choose
a novel in my opinion it doesn't have to
be today but within a couple of weeks a
novel for which we have both the ebook
and the audiobook
so that you can listen to it and you can
study it and then in all of this
material
the newspapers the magazines the
audiobook
my blog you want to be saving words and
phrases
so that this vocabulary these phrases
become part of your
english right
and so so that's the second thing is is
working on these different things that's
that are going to improve your english
level and the third thing i want to work
on is
because i'm often you know i'm often
very much influenced by the latest thing
i've done
so i've recently started doing this
crossfit you know what crossfit is
okay so in fact i'm going to crossfit at
noon today
so the interesting thing about crossfit
is that it's a limited number of
exercises lots of squats lots of presses
with weights like it's a limited number
of exercises
but the idea is that
this limited number of exercises
is very beneficial because it works so
many other muscles you're not just
sitting at a machine doing this
you actually have to stand you have to
do things using all of your muscles so i
believe that in language learning
there are certain
activities
that are extremely beneficial
and that's what we're going to explore
sort of as a
limited list of things that have a lot
of benefit
and we'll get into that but it does
relate to basically words and phrases
it's my belief that if you have an
efficient way
of acquiring words and phrases
that that is kind of like the base
for your language learning everything
else will come from that
pronunciation ability to speak well
we're going to do presentations we're
going to talk about how to make better
presentations but it all boils down to
developing a rich vocabulary of words
and phrases and we're going to discuss
different techniques within link
that or outside link that help you
acquire those words and phrases so that
is by way of introduction
you